[Music]
oh
gah
didn't see you there
aren't you supposed to be
leaving presents
no you're thinking of my brother Santa
I'm takings clause
takings clause
with an E
you don't know your Constitution do you
I learned about it in school
public school
it gives us ourrights
yeah that's public school
look the Constitution doesn't give you rights
it protects the rights you have from the government
but it's not doing a great job so
I get to take your stuff
My stuff
Fifth Amendment right there read it
nor shall private property be taken for public use
withoutjust compensation
boom
what's just compensation
I already gave it to you
this is just a pocketConstitution
it's not just a constitution
it's just compensation
this is #$%^&*!
yeah a little bit
aren't you going to compensate me for that
no I didn't take that I broke it
but you broke it you buy it
yeah well we'll find out soon enough
Devillier v Texas Supreme Court
the what v Texas
Texas basically built a concrete
dam alongside Route 10
to keep the road dry
but the other side of the
road
was somebody's Ranch so
when it rained a lot
the ranch turned into a lake
and a bunch of cows
and horses died
and you know
that's awful
yeah yeah yeah real sad
but the point is
they didn'tmean for that to happen
it just happened
so tough luck
then I'll sue you
yeah no I have qualified
immunity
cuz I'm acting in an official capacity
well where's new process clause
or equal protection clause
aren't you a little old believe in those
<sad puppet noise>
this is the worst time of year
I mean
electionseason's right around the corner
#$%^&*!